[MUSIC PLAYING]
RON JOLLY: Journalism
today, I believe, just
about everybody reporting the
news has some kind of agenda.
They're starting off
point is not ground zero,
it's from where they are
on the left or the right.
And it's very confusing or very
difficult for news consumers
to find anything to trust.
So it's crucial that we
really examine what journalism
is and should be and teach
people proper journalism,
because it's the conduit.
It's what we all need.
It's what ties us
together and how
we communicate and understand
what's going on in our city,
our town, our world.
I have throughout much of
my career on talk radio
interviewed professors,
people from Hillsdale.
And I said during the
interview, why don't we
have more Hillsdale
Colleges in this country?
And I got a letter a couple
of weeks later and they said,
we really agree with you.
So we're going to start a
scholarship in your name
for Hillsdale College.
I just-- I was beside myself.
I couldn't believe it.
The scholarship will be used
for a bright, ambitious student
from Michigan who is interested
in journalism and radio.
The journalism program
at Hillsdale College
has produced great
success stories.
We have former students
of Hillsdale now working
at The Wall Street
Journal, The Detroit News,
and many other publications.
The radio and journalism
program at Hillsdale,
Radio Free Hillsdale,
has won numerous awards.
And they've just been named
the best college radio station
in Michigan.
Hillsdale College has a
great journalism program
because the students there,
like all Hillsdale students,
they learn about
foundational things
they should know,
like our constitution,
why do we have freedom in this
country, what's it all about.
And it gives them context
to report on everything.
So you match a classical
education with journalism,
and you're going to produce
responsible, trustworthy,
knowledgeable journalists
in the future.
This is a matching scholarship.
And that means anybody
who supports Hillsdale
for the education
that they provide,
you can donate any amount
and it will be doubled.
So you can donate $10 and
you'll make an impact, and that
will be doubled, $20, $100,
any amount, $1,000, $10,000,
you name it, please give
to the Ron Jolly Challenge
at Hillsdale College
before our deadline.
And remember, whatever
you give will be doubled.